joining me now for reaction is former
independent counsel Fox News contributor
Ken Starr along with former US Attorney
Brett Tolman and criminal defense
attorney David Shawn great to have all
three of you here Judge Starr let me
begin with you thank you you know I
remember the Comey testimony vividly
because I write extensively about it in
my book and you know it strikes me that
if there's an email that essentially you
know Loretta Lynch the Attorney General
is saying I'm not going to let this case
go too far against Hillary Clinton my
goodness doesn't that need to be
declassified yes indeed Greg I think you
and I and the American people are in
agreement
we need more rather than less and there
should especially in light of all the
questions very serious questions about
the integrity of the FBI's leadership
and even touching on the Justice
Department during that period in 2016
before the president was elected we need
declassification happily as you know
President Trump has delegated that
responsibility to the Attorney General
United States built bar who's very
experienced and he's going to do a very
professional job of protecting national
security sources and methods but also
then getting the information out that we
the people need in order to make our own
judgement about what happened
David the evidence is pretty compelling
that the fix was in that Hillary Clinton
was not going to be charged and I'll
point your attention but what Peter
struck said in private testimony he said
that it was the DOJ attorneys that told
the FBI to charge to change gross
negligence to extremely careless and
then his lover Lisa page testified that
the DOJ said quote you're not going to
charge gross negligence was the fix in
absolutely I'm it's very very troubling
and remember remember Michael Horowitz
the Inspector General said that he
didn't have access to all of the emails
so we still haven't seen some of the
emails between struck and page you
discussed this stuff brilliantly at
your book starting at page 40 about this
whole fix that clearly was in and
there's a question judge Starr spoke
beautifully earlier and he's absolutely
right
but there's a real question as to
whether and why this information was
classified in the first place I frankly
just don't believe former director Comey
that there was a need for it to be
classified Brad I wonder if you believe
Comey because on the day cleared Hillary
Clinton he said I have not coordinated
or reviewed this statement in any way
with the Department of Justice or any
part of the government they don't know
what I'm about to say then how come four
days earlier Paige sent a text that said
she Lynch knows no charges will be
brought yeah this is one of the more
shocking discoveries I think for many of
us that worked in the Department of
Justice Jim Comey held himself out as
having the white hat he was the guy that
was all about transparency all about the
rules following the rules you look at
what he said in that hearing and he says
I I would have to give a classified
answer in response to that well he stuck
with that and he continued to use that
as the defense mechanism to reveal the
things that he was doing many of us that
were in the Department of Justice worked
with Jim Comey would have fired Jim
Comey instantly on many of the issues
that we now know he was involved in and
how he handled them and Judge Starr I
mean the twist on all of this is
reportedly it was the Russians that
intercepted this email which only
underscores that Hillary Clinton really
did jeopardize national security with
her private unauthorized unsecured
server even though President Obama said
oh gee she didn't jeopardize national
security yes and that can't be right it
absolutely was so unconscionable that
the Secretary of State would do what she
did and do it intentionally and the
changing of the characterization I think
is well to me it's unpardonable do you
do not when the FBI comes forward with a
conclusion based
on there a very careful evaluation of
all the facts then say no we're going to
change that
that's not your view your view is
instead a softer and gentler view and so
there's just an enormous and number of
questions about the professionalism
frankly of the DOJ and its relationships
with the FBI leadership in particular
during the course of the Obama
administration and the Loretta Lynch
email if this is true is absolutely
explosive because that shows that there
is a very serious issue of integrity at
the very top of the Justice Department
if people like Loretta Lynch David at
the Department of Justice made a
decision on not to charge for political
reasons is that obstruction oh
absolutely it's obstruction and several
other things it's so problematic listen
as I've told you before my father was an
FBI agent we're very proud of that what
these people did Comey McCabe struck
page this whole crew tore down the
reputation of one of the greatest
agencies in the history of the country
and so-called civil libertarians like
Nadler Jerry Nadler should be outraged
by it they should be outraged by the
people they've embraced that tells you
that their Trump hatred outweighs
everything else in their agenda and
that's not what they were elected to do
where at all that you have the last word
well I'll tell you we should be afraid
of what pattern we're starting to see we
have seen the director of the FBI follow
a pattern of hiding things that he
doesn't want us to see leaking things
that he hopes to get out they're not
charging Hillary Clinton when when many
of us thought there should have been
charges and why why does he come out
right before the election because he
thought she was gonna win and he was
gonna cover for after she became
president then the same pattern seems to
occur with the FISA Court when we have
the steel dossier and and the the almost
actionable you know request from the FBI
to the FISA Court that we now know is
not accurate so what we are seeing is a
that should scare folks that's what
Congress should be looking into is what
is it those in power are doing with the
power they have abusive power and
corruption to perpetuate power judge Ken
Starr Bret thank you David as always
appreciated